joining us now with Morris Minority Whip
Steve Scalise and house freedom caucus
chairman Andy Biggs gentlemen thanks so
much for joining us congressman Scalise
this is kind of bizarre you know Chuck
Schumer's press conference about how
they wanted more evidence aren't they
kind of de facto admitting that they
impeached the president without evidence
am i reading this wrong
he needs more witnesses but they already
took a vote saying oh they had enough
evidence to impeach if it seems kind of
backwards yeah we said this all along
there literally was no crime the
president committed no crime it was an
impeachment in search of a crime and
they never found one all of their own
witnesses their star witnesses all said
that there was no crime there was no
bribery and now you've got Pelosi really
carrying out her own quid pro quo she's
trying to say I won't give you the
papers unless you do this isn't that
what they were accusing president Trump
of look Joe Biden did the quid pro quo
that he bragged about you know hey I'll
take the billion dollars of taxpayer
money if you don't fire the prosecutor
Pelosi is doing a quid pro quo president
Trump's the only one who didn't do one
and they impeached him for it this is
bizarre and look there is no case it's
time for her to give this up stop the
witch hunt and finally start working for
the American people
we could be lowering drug prices we can
have a secure border and do so many
other things but there are the party of
impeachment this is all they have no
congressmen before I go to congressman
Biggs I just following up on that
congressman Scalise you know it's
fascinating because they allege the quid
pro quo with the president that their
only first-hand witness said never
happened Gordon Sunland and yet the
president's the chief executive of the
country was obviously concerned about
corruption and foreign aid he said that
many times and yet now we have Nancy
Pelosi with a unconstitutional
usurpation of the Senate powers and
where's the media on this no we're
celebrating how wonderful Nancy Pelosi
is am I reading this wrong you're
spot-on and look when the media was kept
out of the room by Adam Schiff
where was the media then saying we're
not gonna let you a peach a president in
secret behind closed doors this is Nancy
Pelosi literally saying she has no case
she's she's already lost one Democrat
over this fiasco last week
Jeff Andrew said enough already I'm not
going to be a part of this anymore
who knows how many more she's gonna lose
either by switching or a lot of them are
just gonna get beat next year because
the country is fed up with these
theatrics this this drama by speaker
Pelosi trying to now take over the
Senate because she has no case in the
house shouldn't have moved to
Pietschmann in the first place but they
didn't anyway the country says look
focus on Lauren drug prices and caring
about the Working Families
fortunately President Trump cares about
those families and is delivering with a
great economy with a lot of people with
a lot more money in their paychecks this
Christmas
congressman Biggs you know I gotta
believe that the Democrats up there for
as much as I disagree with their rancid
political ideology they're not stupid
they're not they're usually a little bit
more tactically efficient they have to
know this has been just a spectacular
faceplant public polling is down
independents moving in the opposite
direction swing state polls devastating
minority support for President Trump
going up I saw some number raising
millions of dollars on the day of
impeachment for President Trump are you
sensing upon the hill that some of the
31 Democrats and Trump districts are
starting to say you know houston we got
a problem here we may want to slow this
down is that where this is coming from
well some of them are concerned but
others are kind of stuck in the middle
with Nancy Pelosi so I think you've got
some that are more rational that are
saying hey this is a real problem for us
but you know Dan what you're seeing is
really a reflection of the authoritarian
nature of the left and the Democrat
Party so so Nancy Pelosi is going to go
out there and basically compel her
members to go for an impeachment that
does not have popular support and does
not as you pointed out have evidence and
if if they get through this and if it
ever gets over to the Senate and he's
acquitted which we all know he will be
they're gonna do it again
that's the authoritarian nature that you
see within the Democrat Party that
actually beats down on those 31
Democrats within that those swing
districts and so they're all in trouble
they're all in trouble
congressman Scalise is following up on
this this is the aoc left left leaning
far left leaning wing of the party do
they really have this much power as I
was talking about before here at
congressman Biggs my question here she
has to know this could lead to win
electoral disaster I mean if this leads
to a Republican retaking of the house a
holding in the Senate and a landslide
victory for Donald Trump this is going
to stain her legacy forever I thought
Nancy Pelosi was smarter than this you
deal with her in your leadership
position again I I'm what am I missing
in this she's usually tactically smarter
than this well in you know she used to
be in control of that caucus and now
with this new socialist Democrat Party
AOC as you were indicating AOC is
driving the train now it's her party if
you go back to the impeachment inquiry
that she wasn't gonna do an impeachment
and then one weekend AOC tweeted that
the real crime is the Democrat majority
not impeaching President Trump and
literally two days later Nancy Pelosi
said she was going to peach the
president so AOC is driving this party
it's why so many of the moderates have
no place left there are no blue dogs
left in the Democrat Party virtually
she's run them all off because they're
tired of the socialist style but that's
all she's got and they're controlling
things right now that's a great point I
forgot about that tweet congressman
Biggs nothing they've told us about this
impeachment the Democrats is true there
was no quid pro quo there firsthand
witnesses told us the exact opposite
Gordon Sandlin zone tech said the
president's been crystal clear no quid
pro quo like they can read it themselves
I know they don't do evidence the left
or anything like that but everything
they told us about the extreme nature of
it to be rushed we have to get this
prezi such a danger to national security
that's nonsense so they were in a rush
and now all of a sudden they want to
slow down all oh yeah again a little bit
of a disconnect with their messaging now
yeah oh absolutely right and they it
shows the disarray that they have and
you're right I think Nancy Pelosi is
normally pretty strategic but she's
getting the pressure from the left but
they are in disarray right now and and
it actually is undermining the very
nature of what they think they're going
to do in the future in the 2020 election
so it really has consequences electoral
e it has consequences for us
constitutionally of course and within
the institution itself but they're in
disarray she's misread this thing
terribly I don't know who's advising her
right now but she had a fire me get
somebody else congressman Scalise
congressman Biggs seriously thank you
very much you fight
fight up they we really appreciate it
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas again for joining us